[Music]  [Music]  be my man you made it you blown up all  over the news are you alone I just want  the money you got the chip all right  start it up back why don't you go to the  bathroom wash up we gonna be with you in  a minute  aha come on man your neck it's a mess  initiating combat mode  destination  all right in and out [ __ ] we're rich  oh we are going to the major leagues  charity  Jake Oh sick  get through clinic now it's toilets  condition critical immediate medical on  hey hey just think about all the good  [ __ ] we're gonna have huh oh sorry  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  take the [ __ ] shift X every corporate  cop in this city is gonna be blasting  down these doors after what you and your  psycho Franti we didn't need all this  [ __ ] attention damn it  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  wait the [ __ ] off samurai we have a city  to burn